oh  [Music]  hey stop the car stop  you stay here no what are you doing here  turn the car off  turn the car off now  turn the car off now turn the car off  now  [Music]  [Music]  on your back  [Music]  [Music]  oh  oh  oh  sit down  stop touching me  that's why  you're gonna wait i'm mad okay  this didn't have to be like touching me  it did because you were aggressive for  no reason all right  you know you're wrong and i take your  whole job  what the fuck  you got  me  i kicked this whole call my mama  listen  don't bro she can talk to me you can't  take it to me check her you can't say  hold me face my fuck up i will if you  were just  a second okay  um  [Music]  [Music]  sir  take that inside and keep filling it up  i got you  okay  don't touch me  okay i'm trying to put on new ones so  we're live  oh  don't push  oh my god  oh  oh  [Music]  fix my wrist okay give  go back inside please